[Music]
well there's quantum mechanics you see
now quantum mechanics it consists of two
parts you see this is basically I
learned from Dirac about the puzzles of
quantum mechanics I think it was partly
because I dozed off at the beginning it
wasn't actually in my mind was a certain
point this is his very first lecture no
I didn't know you see it was right at
the beginning and he was talking about
the superposition principle they see if
you have a particle and if this one
state of the particles it's here another
state of the particles it's here then
you can have states where it's here and
here at the same time so you can see
particles can be in two places at once
crazy if that South quantum mechanic
works then he took a piece of chalk and
I think he broke it in two and said look
the chalk is now imagined it's here and
here at the same time this was the point
my mind wander did you see because he
gave some explanation I think sort of
faint the faintest idea what it was I
just remembered something about the word
energy coming into it and I'm worried
about then ever since you see so why is
it that you don't have pieces of chalk
in two places at once people in two
places at once and all that and this is
a big problem in quantum mechanics so my
view was that quantum mechanics can't be
quite right and Einstein had that view
yes yes this is a little bit more
specific because it has to do with why
is it not right but that took me longer
to think about that but the view is that
it can't be quite right and the way in
which it's not quite right has to be
taken advantage of by the brain so this
was the idea that I had and I wrote this
book the emperor's new mind I thought
probably it would disappear without
trace but then Stephen Hawking
written his book on the brief history of
time and he had got what's-his-name
Carl Sagan who writer before which so I
thought actually gets done buddy decent
to write a foreword then maybe so I got
Martin Gardner so I I had no idea what
Martin Martin Gardner's views when he
said yes I agree with you he says so he
he was happy to write forward and then I
thought well it's probably won't
disappear without trace
know the difference between the two
books is that brief history of time the
Hawking's about that big and Rogers
handy-dandy quick primer for
consciousness about Pathak it's got
pictures yes
but it's interesting is this - lot of
people hated it yes they did
oh gosh that I was making a series on
consciousness at the time and again my
whole life has been mentioning you and
people going like this yeah because they
the criticism was that all rogers has
done is taken a mystery and wrapped it
in enigma and said there you go taking
two things we didn't understand and say
because we don't understand these two
things they must be the same thing
that's not the argument at all they
haven't read the book
no it's true but the thing is you see I
had no idea what the answer was so I
wrote the book thinking that by the time
I had to learn some neurophysiology and
that sort of thing by the time I'd love
that bit I would see where there give me
something going on in the brain see the
argument had to be that it had to be
some effect where gravity comes in and I
had no idea at that time it didn't seem
to be the propagation had any chance of
being the answer and the thing is you
see I was hoping that this book would be
read by young people trying to learn
about science and so on most of the
letters I got from people from old
retired people and those were the people
who had time to read the book I guess
but anyway not just old retired people
one person who did read the book was
Stuart Hameroff yes Stuart Hameroff his
day job is to put people and maybe in
the night to and it put people to sleep
reversibly in other words do you give
them general general anesthetics when
they have operations
and unlike most of his colleagues who
were just as capable of putting people
to sleep and waking them up afterwards
they didn't seem to worry as much as he
did about what they were actually doing
yeah so this point was what do the
general anesthetics act on and his view
was that they act on these things called
microtubules and so he sent me a letter
and you said the thing missing from your
argument is you haven't mentioned
microtubules and I thought microtubules
I get lots of letters from lots nutty
people you see oh gosh it's another one
but then I looked it up and I saw the
yeah they're real I should know I should
have known about them and these are
little tiny tubes and I thought the
chance of preserving quantum coherence
that level was much much greater than in
just the last year or two a lot more
people are coming around to this idea
because the problem was always people
said but can you maintain quantum states
in the brain because the brain is a
noisy messy and warm place which is
generally not good for quantum generally
if we want to do anything with quantum
mechanics we we buy a truckload of
liquid nitrogen and freeze the entire
place down and then we start we they and
some people didn't like it but in the
last two years a lot of new people are
starting because they've realised
actually they can find participe Hrant
quantum stuff in the brain where they
didn't expect it so so Rogers detractors
are all feeling bit peeved at the moment
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you